I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight we start
with the startling breaking news
detailing exactly how Twitter censored
the bombshell Hunter Biden laptop story
in the run-up to the 2020 presidential
election
but first it's important to remember how
this all began in April of 2019 Hunter
Biden dropped off three water damage
laptops at a Delaware computer shop for
repair so after 90 days Hunter had still
not returned to pick him up now it was
then that the owner of that store John
Paul Mac Isaac started searching key
terms like barisma after hearing them
during Trump's first impeachment trial
well upon finding numerous hits Isaac
contacted an intermediary who in turn
contacted the FBI in November of 2019
the FBI came to his home where he was
keeping the laptops and they reportedly
made forensic copies but left the
devices behind only return for them very
months later now in 2020 Isaac stopped
hearing from the FBI so he reached out
to Congressional members who likewise
ignored the findings
they remained Under Wraps until he
contacted a lawyer of Rudy Giuliani
in October 2020 details of the hard
drive were published by the New York
Post
now due to the chain of custody of the
laptop the Deep State saw a way to spin
it
more than 50 former senior intelligence
officials they said a disputed set of
emails from Joe Biden's son 100 they
have all the classic earmarks of Russian
disinformation operation right-wing
media has been focused on Hunter Biden
this laptop that intelligence officials
have warned or is likely Russian
disinformation to say that there's no
evidence this hard drive is part of a
potentially a Russian disinformation
campaign doesn't make any sense to me
now despite zero evidence of this social
media companies Twitter Chief among them
moved to stifle this story they even
suspended the New York Post Twitter
account you remember that well the
message had gone out
this story was not to see the light of
day and elements that did must be
labeled Russian disinformation
well tonight we finally learned the
details about how the coordination
effort unfolded and it came in a very
interesting manner
Elon Musk gave former Rolling Stone
writer Matt taibi currently of substack
the Reigns and taking folks through all
of this taibi wrote Twitter in its
conception was a brilliant tool for
enabling instant mass communication
giving people the power to create and
share ideas and information instantly
without barriers in an early conception
Twitter more than lived up to its
mission
as time progressed however the company
was slowly forced to add those barriers
some of the first tools for controlling
speech were designed to combat the likes
of spam and Financial fraudsters
so how did this ultimately manifest
itself well taibi through musk writes
this is the bombshell here by 2020
requests from connected actors to delete
tweets were routine
one exec would write to another more to
review from the Biden team
the reply would come back handled
wow joining me now is Molly Hemingway
Fox News contributor and editor-in-chief
at the Federalist Mike Davis of the
internet accountability project he also
clerked for Supreme Court Justice Neil
Gorsuch and Charlie Kirk founder of
Turning Point USA Mali we've been
waiting for this information obviously
we're going to learn more and more as
time goes on but what do you make of the
evolution from Twitter in its early days
to Twitter in the election cycle of 2020
especially in the fall with a laptop
story having been revealed this social
media company changed so much about how
we can communicate it started out as a
platform for free speech free thought
and free debate what happened in the
2016 election was that former president
Donald Trump then a candidate was able
to bypass the propaganda and hostility
of corporate media by using social media
to speak directly to the American people
and it worked and he won election when
that happened social media companies
said they would never let it happen
again they began widespread campaigns of
de-platforming censorship algorithmic
game playing and meddling in all of our
elections on behalf of their favored
Democrat candidates this really did I
think the perfect example is this story
where we are learning so much about what
Twitter did to suppress free speech and
debate about the Biden family business
and its possible corruption that was in
this Biden laptop story and learning
details we need you know they're
learning who was involved how much
Democrats were involved in suppressing
this news that Americans had every right
to know before election day that was
kept from them by these Bad actors
Mike I want to go to you because as you
read what Matt taibi is releasing with
his sub stack number nine point number
nine is that celebrities and unknowns
alike
could be removed or reviewed at the
behest of a political party okay then it
goes on to say both parties had access
to these tools for instance in 2020 a
requests from both the Trump White House
and the Biden campaign were received and
honored but the system wasn't balanced
because Twitter itself taibi goes on to
say was of one political overwhelmingly
of one political orientation so there
are more channels in other words to
complain about what conservatives were
doing or Trump supporters were doing
then the other way around your reaction
tonight Mike these big Tech platforms
have way too much power they're too big
they're too powerful and when you have
these political actors including
government actors that can reach out to
these big Tech platforms and say
something is misinformation or
disinformation and then gets the
information censored and people
de-platformed we have serious problems
we have a First Amendment problem with
this but we just have a general problem
where these big Tech platforms can throw
elections and if the American people
would have known what was on that laptop
that laptop from hell that the New York
Post got censored over President Biden
would not be in the white house today
well Charlie that's the rub is it not
because we know for a fact uh that a lot
of Americans have reported that they
would have reconsidered their vote had
they known the extent of the Biden
family corruption uh as a result from
the hunter Biden Saga and now we find
out that because of this slant and
political orientation that's Point 12
that taibi tweeted tonight
um that you know we see that the
assessment of of current and former high
level high-level Executives was only
going one way so again this reveals just
how the bias played out in real time
during October of 2020.
direct campaign intervention and Laura
what bothers I think so many Americans
is that they thought that they were
getting the whole story in the fall of
2020. when Elon Musk bought Twitter I
don't think he quite realized that he
was actually buying a Democrat Super PAC
you know this this puts an entirely
different phrasing on the story on the
idea of kill the story now you have this
ability or you had the ability as the
Biden campaign to just make a story
disappear you don't like the hunter
Biden laptop story you don't like a
story that you know might be a threat to
your political campaign just email your
friends at Twitter and it can vanish
from the entire landscape what we are
learning is that this was
interdepartmental too you had the former
intelligence officials 50 of them sign a
letter you had federal law enforcement
you have Twitter how far they went and
how shaky this is on so many different
levels it will forever question and
taint the 2020 election the more we
learn about this and I'm glad Elon Musk
has the courage to declassify or to do
the equivalent of declassification and
let this be known transparency is the
answer here well Molly I think another
key thing here is that what what they're
saying in the release of these documents
is it's not you know you just can't take
their word for it taibis or mosque this
is the Viewpoint of current it says
multiple current and former high-level
execs at Twitter are confirming this so
that's pretty that's pretty shocking in
and of itself is it not that's true and
there's also documents documentary
confirmation of this as well and I love
that we're getting this information
about the hunter Biden story that was a
horrible suppression but it's also
important that people understand that
this type of suppression of news and
information that hurts Democrats was
going on for years prior to the 2020
election this is just one notable
example when you think about how many
votes are affected by this manipulation
of information this disinformation that
comes out by pretending that certain
information isn't there or that other
information is more valuable it is it
has profound consequences and there
needs to be a lot more I'm so glad we
mentioned that the FBI was involved in
this you know we'd already learned that
Mark Zuckerberg that Facebook officials
were met with by FBI officials who were
told who told them to look out for this
type of information to suppress it this
is something that the new Republican
Congress is going to need to demand
answers from for the government
officials that were involved and also
everyone should remember that just
because intelligence officials say
something does not mean you should
believe it in fact I would say given
their track record you should almost
disbelieve it yeah and Mike that's uh
that applies I think to these Rosy
assessments of the war in Ukraine covid
all the things that have led people to
take very drastic actions in their own
personal lives and support various
efforts around the world that uh that
the Biden Administration is pushing I
want to go to point 18 in this flurry of
tweets that Matt taibi set out at the at
the behest of Elon Musk tonight Twitter
took extraordinary steps to suppress the
story removing links and posting
warnings that it may be quote unsafe
they even blocked its transmission via
direct message a tool hitherto reserved
for extreme cases like child pornography
so so Mike they were able to stop you
from communicating with your your
trusted friends and colleagues and
Associates on direct message about about
Hunter Martin That's How worried they
were about this wow the New York
unbelievable the New York Post is the
old one of the oldest newspapers in
America and they were able to shut down
the New York Post over this this shows
that big Tech has too much power they
have gatekeeping power ridiculous
yeah exactly we need to break up big
Tech they have way too much power and we
have seen over and over that they're
willing to use their power to crush
conservatives and others with whom they
disagree well and Charlie this leads us
to discuss the house now which is of
course going to be in Republican hands
Kevin McCarthy will likely be the
speaker of the house uh he has been
known to be more friendly in the past
than others uh to Big Tech he received
enormous amount of money over the years
from Big tech companies I mean we we
like Kevin McCarthy we've had been on
the show many times but this is where
the rubber meets that you know what road
here I don't care who gave you
contributions this must stop this is
these are proxy sensors for the left
right now and this has to stop because
it's going on as Molly said across the
board on all these big tech companies
we need a church and Pike committee
equivalent immediately out of the gates
in January I want to see Jack Dorsey
subpoenaed I want to see Edgar wall
subpoenaed and I want to have them
answer under oath exactly why did they
use the instruments of power for what
was supposed to be the Public Square
during an election to benefit a
candidate I mean were any laws broken
here did they knowingly do this even
though they knew that the story was
false why did they do this was there
another reason was there a kind of a
quid pro quo that Twitter was not going
to be broken up by a section 230 if
Biden got in the white house and they
would just kind of turn to Blind Eye
these are questions that need answers
immediately and then there needs to be
some form of Justice to this because
everything that Americans will teach
their children about fair play and
following the rules was obliterated by
the alleged Public Square which was
Twitter during the fall of 2020 and
unfortunately Laura they got their way
we know how voters would have voted if
this story would have allowed to have
virality and let this be no this right
there was the stoppage of the
transmission of of what could have been
the end of the Biden campaign and just
tragically the sensors and the bad guys
were able to squeak through yeah who
doesn't think that this had
significant effect Molly on the election
when in some states things were fairly
close and obviously all the concerns
about irregularities and so forth the
idea that this would have had no impact
or minimal impact we don't know that we
don't know that at all
I have to mention I wrote a book called
rigged how it would be a big Tech and
Democrats seized our elections and this
was a big part of it you're absolutely
right that it was a close election it
came down to three states forty thousand
votes the idea that this doesn't manage
to affect in not just this story but so
many stories the algorithmic game
playing that Google does where it
suppresses news and information from a
public from Republicans while elevating
news and information from Democrats the
um there are so many ways in which big
tech companies are able to put their
um put their hand on the scale in favor
of their political allies it affects
probably millions of votes it is an
existential threat to the Republican
party yes but it's also an existential
threat to our country we have seen how
these big Tech social media platforms
have been able to create in people this
idea that we shouldn't be able to debate
or that speech that is unpopular should
be suppressed you know violently instead
of believing in the confidence of our
first amendment that we have the the
right and responsibility to argue for
our position to seek truth to have
freedom of speech freedom of the press
freedom of assembly these these
platforms are almost more powerful than
our government they frequently are and
so it's a threat to the entire Republic
what they're doing and you see how much
the left is freaking out about just one
social media platform not doing what
they do and it's not like Elon Musk is
helping out Republicans he's just saying
that there should be some more open
expression and he's not even doing a
perfect job with it but just moving in
that direction they are freaking out
because they know how much of their
political power is thanks to these big
Tech social media platforms yeah you bet
and this is why they were so uh upset
and freaking out about Elon Musk taking
over Twitter
um and Charlie or let's Mike Davis let's
go to you on this this is uh tweet 21 of
the Matt taibi sub stack on this or
tweet on this excuse me public policy
executive Caroline storm Strom note
regarding Kaylee mcanoon mcanany being
locked out of her account return the
answer that the laptop story had been
removed for violation of the company's
hacked materials policy so Mike they uh
they kept her locked out Kaylee she was
a White House employee at the time and
she was merely merely discussing yeah
she was top White House communications
official and she's merely talking about
something that's true and they locked
her out for that wow it's amazing that
again this is a good test for Kevin
McCarthy if he actually wants the votes
to become speaker he needs to change his
position uh and support these key
bipartisan anti trust reforms to finally
break up big Tech's gatekeeping power
Charlie the
nine percent of Voters think that
truthful coverage of the laptop Hunter
Biden's story would have changed the
outcome of the election
so that's 79 imagine if we had a meeting
that was honest about covid that was
honest about the true state of our
economy that was honest about Hunter
Biden
Charlie your response yeah it's worse
than them not covering the story they
covered it up that's what's so
incredible is that there were active
steps to actually use the instruments of
power to prevent any sort of virality or
discussion you would lose your Twitter
account you wouldn't be allowed to
direct message it I mean in in any way
how is this any different than living in
the equivalent of a totalitarian
dictatorship when it comes to elections
on the technological landscape I mean I
know that's a very serious thing to say
but how is it any different descent is
not allowed you come across a laptop
that is that that has emails and
Communications tied to the soon to be
president or it's it's it is a test
yeah China would be proud of all of this
we're going to continue to follow all
the details tonight Molly Mike Charlie
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else